we're here in front of stage two now
home to the neighborhood but it is where
they used to film the original Roseanne
show Nancy and that show premiered
thirty years ago this week and now
tonight on ABC is the debut of the
highly anticipated spin-off but here's
the big question can the Condor survive
without Roseanne
don't touch anything I've got a system
and just release clips and
behind-the-scenes footage the Connors
take selfies and shoot a new family
photo but no obvious confirmation how
Roseanne's character is killed off I'm
assuming that people will be curious
about the first one and then hopefully
they'll they'll feel like they they're
in good hands with the family it was
emotional moving forward Sara Gilbert
and John Goodman told GMA at first it
was awkward filming without Roseanne who
was fired for sending a racist tweet it
was like there was a death in the family
their speculation Roseanne's character
dies of an opioid overdose Michael
Fishman who plays DJ told us today that
her absence brings a new depth to the
Connors I think what people are gonna
see starting with Laurie Metcalf John
Goodman and Sarah everybody steps into
kind of these new roles because that's
what happens when you when a family
member is not there there is a big void
that you have to fill and there's a new
Connor cast member deejays military wife
who as a child he refused to kiss in a
school play I would say in describing
our relationship I would say I'm the
boss of course you would say reasonable
but here's the question will viewers
like the Connors without Roseanne you're
a scary little tyrant you're just gonna
compliment me and walk out
it's just as entertaining it's just as
funny ad weeks Jason Lynch who watched
the first couple of episodes says it's
the best new broadcast comedy of the
fall but if you are a fan of Roseanne
the show and not necessarily rather than
the person you won't miss her absence it
will be very interesting to see the
radiance tomorrow now remember more than
18 million people watch the premiere of
Roseanne earlier this year
can the Conners match or even beat that
[Music]